popour 20 h 30. Nous aurons des
ininvités pour décortiquer les
enenjeux qui se seront présentés
auau point de presse.
LeLe chef du parti québécois pet
memettre toute son attention sur
l'l'élection électorale qui s'en
vivient. Pourquoi ne plonge-t-il
papas dans cette bataille
élélectorale intérimaire? Saint-
PiPierre Plamondon, bonsoir.
PlPlusieurs ont dit que vous avz
prpris la bonne décision, que
c'c'était pas le temps d'aller
vovous brûler dans Marie-Victor.
- - On est à moins d'un an des
élélections générales. J'ai la
reresponsabilité de préparer les
trtroupes s du Parti québécois,
prpréparer la plate-forme. Dansa
memesure où le gouvernement
LeLegault ne voulait pas
dédéclencher immédiatement la de
dedes partiels, on regardait ves
unune élection partielle qui
auaurait pu durer plusieurs moià
unune date indéterminée. Parce
ququ'il faut préparer le terrai,
prpréparer les élections
gégénérales, mais également pare
ququ'on a une excellente
cacandidature avec une assise et
unun ancrage local, je pense qun
efeffet, c'est la bonne décisioà
prprendre. Je n'ai jamais résidà
LoLongueuil. Je n'avais pas de
LyLyon. J'ai choisi ma six
cicirconscriptions que
j'j'annoncerai ultérieurement.
- - Il se paraît que ce serait
RiRimouski?
- - Je ferai une annonce
ulultérieurement. On avait
réréfléchi à tout ça au Parti
ququébécois. On va tout simplemt
susuivre notre plan de préparatn
popour des élections qui sont ts
imimportants.
- - M. Nantel qui a été député
dadans ce coin-là pourrait être
cacandidat.
- - Beaucoup de rumeur circulait
c'c'est de bonne guerre. On fera
dedes annonces dans les prochais
jojours. Mais il y a un ordre ds
totout ça. On va suivre ce plan.
- - Est-ce qu'il y aura une
réréunion d'investiture?
- - Il y a toujours une
ininvestiture au Parti québécoi.
C'C'est sûr qu'on a identifié un
cecertain nombre de candidatures
ququi ont levé la main pour cete
papartielle. Il y a des
cacandidatures intéressantes qui
seseront présentées.
- - Perdre une élection, même si
c'c'est une élection partielle,a
reremettait en cause votre
leleadership et l'avenir du Pari
ququébécois.
- - Ou le temps du chef du Parti
ququébécois est bien investi? E-
cece que c'était le terrain, en
paparlant dans des cégeps ou des
ununiversités, dans des centrese
cocommerce, ou c'est de se
coconcentrer sur un seul compter
susur 125? Pour autant, on a
MaMarie-Victorin parce qu'on
reretrouve énormément
d'd'indépendantistes. Dans la
memesure où on a une bonne
cacandidature intéressante à
memettre de l'avant, évidemment
quque tout ça devait être mis ds
lala balance. Il y aura donc dex
rerendez-vous dans Marie-Victor.
EtEt le rendez-vous décisif, ce
sesera les élections générales.
C'C'est là-dessus qu'on est
coconcentrée au Parti québécois.
- - Il y a peut-être encore
bebeaucoup d'indépendantistes au
QuQuébec, on ne sait pas. Il ree
quque ces gens sont
dédésillusionnés. Parce que c'et
papas à l'ordre du jour. Beaucop
sese sont rangés du côté de la
CACAQ. Les cabinets ministériel,
bebeaucoup de gens sont à la CAQ
etet sont satisfaitsts du discos
nanationaliste. Comment on prépe
unune plate-forme électorale,
cocomment on se prépare à
afaffronter une élection quand n
sasait que la plupart de ses
trtroupes ont été attirés vers n
autre parti?
- - C'est de démontrer qu'on
atattire des gens de qualité qun
auaura des troupes fraîches
efefforts pour les prochaines
élélections. Essaie d'être uniqe
dadans ce qu'on propose. Au nivu
dede la langue française, la loi
dede la CAQ ne va pas assez loi.
UnUnique parce qu'on propose
l'l'indépendance Québec alors qe
lala CAQ accumulent les échecs
dadans toutes ses demandes
rerefusées auprès du fédéral et
dedes vrais demandes importants
cocomme 6 milliards de dollars n
sasanté qui ne sont pas transfés
ouou par exemple application dea
loloi 101 aux entreprises comme
AiAir Canada. En environnement,
susur certaines questions socias
ququi nous tiennent à coeur come
leles CPE, fait il y a toujours
unune crise du logement puis le
gogouvernement ne fête pas gran-
chchose. Plusieurs sujets sur
lelesquels Parti québécois aura
unune proposition qui est
didistinctive est nécessaire por
unun avenir meilleur au Québec.
- - Le défi que vous avez, comme
leles deux parties d'opposition,
leles libéraux sont très faibles
cocomme vous dans les sondages.
DoDonc, est-ce que vous craignez
dede présider ce parti au moment
dede sa dernière respiration, sn
dédéclin ultime?
- - C'est un narratif commencèrt
sosouvent. Je me trouve priviléé
dede dire la vérité sur la
ququestion que le Québec devrait
êêtre un pays. J'entre prochains
élélections parce qu'on va amenr
dedes forces fraîches vives et n
vava être très authentique. On a
dodonner leur juste québécois se
plplaint d'enjeux qui sont vrai.
J'J'ai commencé ma course à la
chchefferie à 5 % et les gens ne
meme mentionnaient pas. Les
sosondages, c'est pas la raison
popour laquelle on fait de la
popolitique. On fait de la
popolitique par conviction et on
auaura de belles convictions à
prproposer aux Québécois lors de
lala prochaine élection.
- - Votre niveau de notoriété
n'n'est pas très élevé. Mais les
sosondages concernant la CAQ sot
trtrès élevés. Essai persistant
dedepuis le début de la pandémie
mamalgré qu'il y a trois partis
d'd'opposition qui frappe fort r
lele gouvernement. Il faut croie
quque c'est pas facile dans
l'l'oppositionon actuellement de
dédémolir le gouvernement. Parce
ququ'elle reste populaire dans
l'l'esprit des Québécois.
- - Les élections, c'est le momt
ouoù on évalue les choix et on
fafait le bilan. C'est important
dede se préparer en fonction de
cecette objectif. Les choses sot
apappelées à changer. On peut ps
sisimplement faire de la politie
enen fonction des sondages parce
quque la seule certitude, c'est
quque les sondages sont appelésà
bobouger. Mieux vaut faire de la
popolitique pour des raisons
prprofondes et attirer des gense
coconviction. Qu'on attire des
gegens intéressants autour de
coconvictions qui sont vraies, i
sosont également nécessaires por
unun ami du Québec meilleur quee
quque nous réserve notre place
dadans le Canada, , déclin
lilinguistique et culturel convi